there's a phrase that andrew breitbart
used to say to me which is whatever
doesn't kill me makes me more famous
that is certainly true of this npr
attempted hit
you know it's always weird to trend on
twitter it happens to me once about
every three weeks
usually my first reaction is okay did i
do anything wrong
it's been a long time since i trended
for doing something that i thought well
i wish i had really hadn't said that
usually i trend for something
unbelievably stupid we trended because
of this npr story
and many people even on the left were
looking at it and saying this is an
insane story especially from a
government-sponsored entity
like npr if you haven't read the piece
the basic premise is this the daily wire
is not untruthful they say this in the
piece the daily wire is a factual
website
the daily wire does not engage in
conspiracy theories they say this in the
piece
the daily wire is not pro january 6th in
fact the daily wire
is not all that controversial in terms
of mainstream points of view
the problem you see according to npr is
that the daily wire
uses facts in a conservative way they
openly say this in the npr piece
and because the daily wire is
conservative and we admit we're
conservative
this means that the daily wires reach on
facebook where we are extremely
successful
should be restricted it should be
restricted because if people are
accessing conservative information it
must be they're doing so because they're
too stupid to recognize its conservative
information
or alternatively even if they know
they're accessing conservative
information
the daily wire is profiting from
polarization now
in one sense the daily wire is profiting
from polarization
we're profiting because polarization
exists meaning there are more than one
poll
in american politics see when you have a
monopoly over information
when you have unipolar politics there's
no polarization
when there is a monopoly from the left
there can be no polarization one pole
means no polarization but when other
perspectives
are now created and allowed to be
disseminated then you get polarization
because there's another point of view
npr asked us for comment we know what
npr is that they're a biased
news source that refuses to acknowledge
their own bias and so yes we had no
interest in commenting for a story that
was designed
to treat us as the enemy it turns out
that a story designed to suppress us
and to get us kicked off of facebook
essentially those are not people who i
feel i owe an interview to
this is part and parcel of a broader
left-wing attempt
to stop social media from disseminating
information that you like to see
to understand why that is you sort of
have to understand how people consume
information right now so it used to be
like even 10 years ago the way that you
would get your information
is by bookmarking all the pages you
liked you'd bookmark daily wired
bookmark daily caller you bookmark
breitbart or drudge report and then you
just go directly to those websites you
click on it you get the information
as the social media giants grew and
people started using more of their time
online
going to the social media giants the
social media giants unleashed news feeds
these news feeds were supposed to
basically cultivate all of those sources
into one place
so everybody started using places like
facebook for their news
the left saw this and they realized
there was an opportunity whereas the
internet had fragmented the sources of
information
that they were used to seeing right we
went from just being able to see the new
york times and the washington post being
able to see all these right-wing sources
social media had re-centralized all of
this and the left thought oh you know
it's a great idea
what if we could convince those social
media websites these new town squares of
information
to shut out conservatives freedom of the
press is designed to prevent the
government from infringing
on the freedom of the press but he's
starting to edge in on first amendment
problems in the white house is
specifically calling out social media
and trying to direct them to suppress
information we're flagging problematic
posts
for facebook that spreads this
information once you have the government
and government-funded sources like npr
directly attempting to pressure private
sources
into quashing dissemination of
information that does become a first
amendment issue here's the thing
npr explicitly says on its own website
that government funding is crucial to
their continued operation
they have to say that because otherwise
the government removes its funding
npr could operate as a fully independent
non-arm of the federal government
but then they would lose their federal
funding which they desperately want
since 2016
the left has basically suggested that
social media is all the problems with
the country the reason hillary clinton
lost
is because these social media companies
have the temerity to allow perspectives
that you liked if only they'd shut down
quote unquote disinformation
then hillary definitely would have won
and not just this information
misinformation so it is no coincidence
that this week there have been a wide
variety of reports
ranging from gizmodo to the washington
post talking about how facebook
should restrict access to information
from the right side of the aisle it's
not a coincidence that's happening the
same time
that the white house is now saying that
social media is to blame for quote
unquote killing people over covet what's
your message to platforms like facebook
[Music]
they're killing people every crisis is
an opportunity
and the crisis of 2016 for the democrats
was an opportunity to go after social
media
the crisis of covid for the democrats
was an opportunity to go after social
media
and now the crisis of conservatives
existing is
the crisis that justifies it going after
conservatives in social media the
takeaway is this
be afraid be very afraid there are
forces in the country right now who are
seeking to quash the dissemination of
information
they really are and this means that you
should find other ways of accessing that
information whether you are bookmarking
websites like the daily wire whether
you're becoming a subscriber the reality
is
that if you are relying on facebook to
continue bringing you the information
you want
and that is definitely a dicey
proposition given the amount of pressure
they are getting from both the
government and from the media to shut
down dissemination of information you
like
the left sees the mere existence of a
conservative website like the daily wire
as a threat and frankly a lot of them
are jealous of the fact that we write
clickable headlines
people actually want to read our stuff
as opposed to the unbelievably boring
tripe npr prints on a regular basis that
constantly mirrors the
perspectives and polarized politics of
the democratic party if you look at the
beginning of the article describing our
utter dominance on facebook
yeah we're good at what we do tough deal
with it